it's a stone yes stone where'd you grow
up everybody Los Angeles well you grew
up with both your parents no no my
father was in and out he had a couple of
households I grew up on my mother's side
most of her brothers were pimps and
hustlers and you know that's what I grew
up being attracted to you know they were
you know well what I thought they were
cuz I see them in the alligator shoes
and you know they used to dress nicely
but I thought once I got older I noticed
that her legs so I kind of do me for a
loop I had a couple of tees I have my
auntie died after taking true loss
I had another auntie die office she shot
she shot here why she had overdosed in
the living room you know I was probably
about nine years old
yup I'd go give my mom she was next door
I had to get her because my attorney was
falling out her mouth man yeah from
there she started changing for me I
story they said a lot different I grew
up in the neighborhood expected you know
I'm saying as I said my father wasn't
there so most of the Jews on the streets
that I seen that was good money was what
interested me that's what I said I want
to because your own role model through
my role models you know Jews Cadillacs
and so-called pimps and you know back
then it was shoving you know saw the
show you know I should still on the
street where the Sherm I'm really not
give to me addresses I don't want the
Sherm was like new in my neighborhood
right and we used to sit outside and
just see people running down the street
but not yet seeing females butt-naked
tripping hug and pose you know we little
kids we run around laughing
and before you knew it we were selling
that [ __ ] you know and this is what our
neighborhood became quite a few of us
gravitated down this way downtown
the rods first came out in my
neighborhood I think I was probably in
about 17 18 years old you know I quit
going to school because I was doing
buddy you know that scene where you
don't Pop's was already tall it's a
little more or less you know Mom you
know you can't tell me what to do I'm
paying half the bills in this place
anyway
so I started coming down here man I did
pretty good for a minute
what's jail quite a few times accomplish
it in all actuality I think I got like
four Prison numbers I've started using
say about 91 92 I had a spyro lost
everything
it was a drunk we should from County
correct okay Spyro lost everything man
out here on the streets you know I went
from here Hollywood was kind of cool at
all man so we were in Hollywood and over
there by McArthur Park and it was like
the [ __ ] was so plentiful and all the
time you know I'm Sam
it really was in we really didn't see
what he was doing to us you know people
that knew you they seen it but I'm out
there every day you know smoking a
handful of this [ __ ] still serving it
this is how I'm keeping my eye on so you
know most of the drug dealers they love
me because I'm never going home I got
half the business coming to you so you
know
it was pretty good for a minute and then
I just I went to jail one time I think
they gave me five for that one they gave
me five for like 93 I got out of 95 and
said I wasn't your [ __ ] waiting no more
so when I got out I kind of still went
back and forth I looked up one of my
homies that was down here
it was really good money and he was like
man such as such only man you know I'm
saying you go get this for me I'll give
you this you know took the stick over
there waiting a cup of time you know
snapped a female that was in the tent
you know sounds a lot bigger than until
a new career was born for him for real
boy I never once showed up again in my
life for the San Liu episode right there
I think my boy gave me about $150 and I
think that took me about three minutes I
was out of here in like three minutes
cashed out he told somebody else I mean
you're starting to do that she starting
to do it so from that point oh man every
damn day everybody out if somebody was
or something something no I'm finna go
through they're tricking and they don't
get paid how often when you walk into
somebody's face and they claim they
don't have the money do they actually
have the money you know times out of ten
if it's somebody that's just smoked out
no they don't but the ones are trying to
serve it yeah I'm not to go up and
bitch's ass to get the money and
everyday you know I'm saying cuz I said
you wouldn't believe it but it's a
plentiful
what's it was the most violent you've
ever had to get to get money out of
somebody
well with this bed and I had to hit this
dude and he actually had the money I
know I broke the arm without he what
kind what kind of bad
it's a Louisville Slugger and smother
the ones that you get at Dodgers they
are the smaller ones the smaller was
yeah wrapped it up with electrical
change much much faster much faster and
it's easy to so anyway and hit him in
the arm I know I broke the arm because
it failed hitting really he still didn't
wanna get it
once I cracked him in here by the time
he told me it was over here and he had
every time so you know I mean people
sometimes people don't understand
nothing but find us the cold part about
it you know and and if they figured that
they can get away or see somebody else
get away with it
and not even pay you your money man for
your puck not gonna tell you [ __ ] but if
you send somebody over there to get it
are they sense of I didn't know they'd
come and get the money and once you're
done once you've done that once
let's try listen now they know when I
come in
yeah cuz I'm not playing and once that
actually curve plus things like that
become an invention so they see me come
hey man look here man I got his money
man take this right here cuz they know
that is we not plane so I mean I'm gonna
stopped a few times they just try to get
me all kind of [ __ ] charges but they
really haven't that know me so as I say
man I stopped something dope he don't
make no sense to me no more
do you use drugs I don't know I use a
little bit of critic
I went through that I went through that
with their Kraken I don't want to go and
see nothing like that you know I got a
daughter
my daughter's 23 I got a glass right now
for the most part man I'm out here to
really just um I do that a little bit I
find it more helping people get hurt
bigger today I really I'm really trying
to see people get the [ __ ] up out here
you know I got a couple of people that
have a sober-living hands and stuff so
if you women you know I'll do what I can
what do you think keeps people down here
and it seems like their their mindset is
that they belong here this is their is
it what they're they're worthy of it
it's actually a lot of people just
addicted to drama drugs has a small bit
to do with it
but I think me personally me personally
and I think that it has a lot to do with
how you was raised whatever went on in
your life people don't want to deal with
problems that they have you know because
what you did to the core of what got you
drilling doing this then you try to find
a solution
you can't just drunk the problem drugs
problem you the problem you gotta figure
out what the [ __ ] going on with you
once you get to the Zagg then you could
probably open it up and start getting
rid of some of that [ __ ] for the most
part now like I say a lot of people
don't do a lot of traumatic [ __ ] in
their life you know cuz I talk to pretty
much everybody and some of the shit's
they've been through until they deal
with that until they actually see it
themselves once you get it on paper and
see it yourself and then see what you
want to do to change it you know for a
long time I thought those 12 steps was
[ __ ] but then I started really
looking at that fourth and fifth step
got a lot of [ __ ] going the hotel cuz
you get to write down and see what's
going on with you and then you go back
and you
apologize that the people who heard was
actually freeze up that spirit was that
spirit is free man you gotta get a
chance to deal with a new you because if
you can honestly trapped in that oh [ __ ]
that's what you're gonna do I think it
was a said to me if you always do what
you always did you gonna always get what
you always got hmm all right stone thank
you so much for talking about the
problem good luck with everything
you